first prime minister i have to ask are
you feeling slightly broody
well it's lovely to meet a family who've
benefited from help to buy
if the tories can't win a majority if
there's an anti-tory majority then
as long as the snp and labour band
together we can keep david cameron out
of downing street most people watching
last night will have realized that no
one's going to win this election
outright
so it's all about who's going to work
with whom i think there were seven
leaders on the stage last night
but there are only two prime ministers
possible after the next election and two
governments
a labour government or a conservative
government people in scotland and i
think people across the uk don't want a
labour government left to its own
devices the inviting impression for me a
clear choice
the competence of the conservatives the
chaos of the rest the liberal democrats
have shown over the last five years that
we can work in coalition to anchor the
government
in the center ground it's only when
working people succeed that britain
succeeds whenever i see a small baby i
always
feel a bit broody but don't worry
there's nothing going to happen on that
front